do you ever hit play and find that your
blueprints aren't working yeah we all do
debugging is a vital part of game
development so I'm going to share with
you some tips on how to debug in Unreal
Engine when setting up blueprints I
always add print strings to visualize
what's happening in the logic on screen
and also in the log I also use draw
debug to visualize the logic in the
world itself a debug sphere is useful to
see location points that the logic is
using breakpoints are great to use as
you can step through your logic because
it will pause the game and for more
information you can open the blueprint
debugger which shows the execution trace
of what logic came before and will also
show any values you are currently
watching o m just remember to remove the
breakpoints after you've finished happy
debugging